hey friends and welcome back to Deep
dive if you're new here my name is Ali
and every week it's my immense privilege
to sit down with authors and
entrepreneurs and academics and creators
and other inspiring people we found out
how they got to where they are and the
strategies and tools we can learn from
them to help us build our best lives to
build lives that we love this episode is
going to be a bit of a Roundup episode
of seven of the lessons that I'm taking
into the next year which have been from
seven different episodes of this season
I can't believe we're at the end of
season four already and it really does
feel like this last year has absolutely
flown by and I've had some absolutely
incredible conversations throughout this
podcast and actually so many that we've
actually pre-recorded for the next
season of the podcast as well so that's
going to be super fun too this year has
also been a pretty exciting year for
this podcast as a whole according to the
stats that we got from spotify's
unwrapped thingy 97 of you discovered
the podcast this year so only three
percent of you were watching or
listening in 2021 which is great to see
the growth and the kind of new
discoverability of the podcast the
podcast was in the top one percent
globally of most shared podcasts so
massive thank you if you have shared the
episodes or the podcast or anything with
friends or family or anyone in your life
and we even managed to break into seven
podcast charts for a total of 275 days
so we stayed in the charts for three
quarters of the year which I think is
pretty good for a seasonal podcast and
very excitingly this podcast has been
listened to just on Spotify alone to
listeners in 147 countries all around
the world now just one final thing for
me before we roll the seven different
lessons that I'm taking into 2023 which
is that um at the moment according to
the YouTube analytics 81 of you who are
watching this on YouTube have not yet
hit the Subscribe button and so if
you're for example in the now 81 of
people who are watching this on YouTube
but who are not subscribed to the
channel I would love it if you could do
so and would be awesome to get that
number down to 50 and it would be cool
to get like 50 50 sub non-sub ratio just
just for fun anyway that's all the
rambling from me thank you so much for
being a watcher a viewer or a listener
of this podcast for the last year and
now let's play The Seven top lessons
that I'm taking away from the season
into the new year what are the things
that we can do to improve our brain
performance
so we talk about
things like
rest which is sleep and also sort of
downtime nutrition is super important so
the brain is obviously a tiny proportion
of your body weight and only weighs a
few kilos but it uses up up to 30
percent of the breakdown products of
what you eat so when you're asleep your
brain is is eating up 20 of what you ate
that day when you're at work
um and focused on something it's using
up about a quarter of what you eat and
when you're stressed it's using up up to
30 percent oh well yeah and so obviously
people think what should I eat if I want
to be healthy generally or I want to
lose weight or I want to build muscle
mass but the sorts of people that you
know like you and the people that I work
with
aren't thinking enough about what should
I be eating so I can make the best
decisions today what should I be eating
so I can solve complex problems what
should should I be eating so I can
understand what's going on like in terms
of interpersonal Communication in my
teeth with my team for example
and then there's everything from
hydration exercise
um breathing mindfulness curiosity like
there's there's so many factors that
contribute
to brain health and
they're probably not dissimilar to
things as a doctor that you would know
contribute to cardiovascular health or
gastrointestinal Health but
you know we at Heights feel that if you
approach everything with a brain care
first attitude then you're kind of
taking care of the rest of the stuff
like if you eat and drink in a way
that's good for your brain your skin and
your hair are going to look nicer I mean
and I that sounds like a such a girly
thing to say but people make a lot of
really important choices based on
what they look like and and that's fine
and that probably has like beneficial
effects on our in our brains and our
guts as well but considering this organ
is so energy hungry and it's so
important in terms of everything else
that happens in your body
I feel like we need to flip that
narrative so that it's starting with
okay what can I what things can I do
today that are going to be the best for
my brain I wonder if we can start with
the nutrition thing then and I guess
what should me and I guess listeners and
viewers be thinking about when it comes
to nutrition like or is it all just the
stuff that everyone kind of knows but
doesn't implement or do you feel like
there's actually a knowledge Gap in an
understanding gap or if it's just a
actually Implement implementing the
things that we all know we probably
should do I like to think there's a bit
of both so I think there's a lot of
things that are in the public domain
that people are aware of that we all
know we should be doing but we're not
necessarily always doing but there are
definitely fun Neuroscience facts that I
can throw in that that I would guess
maybe even you haven't heard of so
should we try yeah perfect yeah okay so
um I would say like level one is that
you eat three healthy meals a day and
and maybe you snack in between if you
need to and when I say healthy mostly
plant-based you know maybe some fish and
eggs minimal amounts of of other types
of meat
um
foods that contain high amounts of water
and good fats so a bit of dairy
fatty fish nuts and seeds berries I mean
I'm already going above level one I
would say with some of those but but you
know three healthy meals a day that kind
of food question on that front yeah
intermittent fasting yeah yeah so level
two oh but that's level two okay if
you're not eating healthily generally
yeah if you're not sleeping around
seven to eight hours fifteen a night
drinking enough water making sure you're
not sedentary don't bother with
intermittent fasting you need to have
those foundations correct if you're
doing all that good stuff and maybe even
meditating then you can take it to the
next level which is
um the first level would be time
restricted eating so for example I only
eat between 12 noon and 8 pm
so I'm essentially doing a 16 hour fast
overnight which has all sorts of
benefits on longevity and cancer risk
reduction and and once you get used to
it it's also it's also good for your
your mental performance
and then the third level which I'm
considering doing again the rest of this
year but I haven't quite got there yet
is what I think is proper intermittent
fasting which is that for two days of
the week you reduce your calorie intake
to for women 500 calories and for men
600 calories a day and the other days of
the week you eat normally
but in all three of those stages you
still have to be eating the kinds of
foods that I mentioned and so this is
tell me whether you knew this or not but
for in terms of brain optimization
eating dark-skinned Foods is much better
than just eating general you know the
leafy greens or the saladskinned yeah
like blueberries rather than
strawberries or raspberries okay purple
sprouting broccoli rather than green
broccoli black beans and black chickpeas
rather than cannellini beans or normal
chickpeas why why something I had no
idea like what so the skin and things
like eggplant as well I think this the
the
um in the skin of Darker foods and
actually you'll like this because it
does include good quality coffee oh
perfect and dark chocolate that's over
80 cocoa
um there are substances called
anthocyanins that are really powerful
antioxidants and they contribute to
something called neurogenesis so there's
three ways of growing your brain if you
like and I and I use that in a as a
metaphor
um
and the hardest one in adults is
for embryonic nerve cells to actually
grow into neurons and connect up with
other neurons in your brain and so
aerobic exercise and foods that contain
high levels of anthocyanins can
contribute to neurogenesis it's going
for a run is good going for a run is
good
um if you're feeling guilty because you
haven't been going for a run then when
you do regular aerobic exercise the cell
turnover is sort of 13 14
of neurogenesis if you have haven't been
doing exercise for some time and you
start again it can actually be up to 30
so to me that's the perfect excuse for
every time I fall off my schedule of
exercise and I start again that I'm
really boosting my neurogenesis but you
know I'm never sedentary but I'm not
always doing like full-on aerobic at
sort of more high intensity exercise so
okay yeah so one mechanism is
neurogenesis the one that makes our
brain grow what are the other two so
neurogenesis is the embryonic cells
growing into new neurons
the next one is synapse synaptic
connection which is already existing
neurons connecting up with each other to
make stronger Pathways and the third one
which you'll be well aware of is
myelination which is a fatty substance
that coats some Pathways in the brain
and body and there's a reason that so
and that leads to faster conduction of
electrical signals along those Pathways
and there are reasons that we have some
Pathways that are myelinated and some
that aren't like for example
if you put your hand in a fire
your reflex to snap your hand out of the
fire is a fast myelinated pathway but
your pain
um pathways are non-myelinated because
if you were incapacitated by the pain of
burning your hand you wouldn't be able
to move or escape from the you know the
threat kind of thing
but what in terms of what we're talking
about which is brain performance
um
basically repetition
can lead to more myelination which means
that that pathway becomes a faster
conducting pathway for you so something
like resisting the urge to you know eat
junk food or
um like there's crisps so some crisps
over there and last night I made the bad
choice to eat the crisps and Gordon kind
of looked at me and like sighed because
I was like whoa there's 200 calories in
these and today I didn't I decided to
leave the chips as they were well that
could be to do with time of day because
your willpower also reduces so during
the day oh yeah maybe
but I mean for me it's mostly about
stimulus control which is that I don't
keep those things yeah it's a yeah it's
a lot easier to resist the chocolate
cake if it's not there
um Okay so we've got neurogenesis from
embryonic cells we've got the synaptic
connections and we've got mother nation
yeah such a pleasure talking to you
because most people are like what were
those things again
how do we tangibly impact those things
so we talked about repetition equals
more myelination and I guess this is
where sort of repetition when it comes
to learning stuff as well like space
repetition over time equals more mother
nation presumably
um what other things can we do to Quick
growth brain so I think in real life
we don't necessarily need to know which
underlying physiological mechanism we're
affecting but we need to know we need to
see the real life result if I'm trying
to learn something or do something
differently and it's working or it's not
working I think the easiest way to just
think about those three is that
the myelination is like something that
you're already good at that it would be
really easy for you to pick up for it to
become your superpower basically
um so for instance and this sounds and I
don't
I don't mean this in a boastful way but
I've got a friend who's a professor of
Neuroscience who plays in a band and I
really admire him for being so good at
an instrument but it really irks him
that I can just learn a new language so
easily so that's like one of my
superpowers
and so I have learned five languages in
my lifetime I'm not fluent in all of
them at the moment but if someone said
to me you know you know do you want to
learn a new language I'd say yeah
because I'll probably be quite good at
that
um but there are lots of other things
that would be much harder for me to
become good at so
that would be for for me that would be
like my a grade subject okay when I take
that unwillingly because I'd probably
find it not too difficult and I'd
probably be quite good at it so think
about what that might be for you and
then
synaptic connection is more like your B
plus which is something that you're not
bad at at all but you don't love and it
doesn't come really easy and naturally
but if you worked really hard you could
make that into an a grade
and then neurogenesis in adulthood
although There Are embryonic cells
around the hippocampus which is where
you know we lay down memories and
learning it's way less than in children
so that would be like
well I did I did this I don't feel like
me taking up golf
um I was really bad at it it took me
ages to improve I would have had to give
up my day job to become you know any
level of decent at it so
um it's it's not wise really in
adulthood to take on a learning that's
so difficult that it's going to detract
from your day-to-day brain performance
um and in that middle category for me I
would probably put something like
let the Tango quite well not amazingly
improved at tennis taught myself
keyboard you know but I'm never going to
be like performing or anything so that's
that's the easiest way to think about
those in your mind like which of those
mechanisms might I be working on because
it's really to do with the level of how
difficult it would be for you just a
quick note from one of our sponsors and
we'll get right back to the episode and
very excitingly this episode is brought
to you by Heights Heights is a brain
care smart supplement that I've actually
been taking for the last 12 months ever
since I became friends with Dan
mariserto who was the founder of heights
and who we had on the podcast in season
one and this season of the podcast we're
also featuring Dr Tara swart who is a
neuroscientist and psychiatrist so what
is Heights well it's a brain care smart
supplement basically it is a supplement
you take two of them every morning like
I do it's like these two little capsules
which have omega-3 oil in them and
they've got a bunch of multi vitamins as
well they have all of the details on the
website it's every single ingredient
they've got is super high quality and
the great thing is that just by taking
two of these capsules every morning like
I do you get all of the essential
micronutrients that you need without
having to deal with drinking sludge or
anything fancy like that so the great
thing about Heights is that even if you
don't have one of these absolutely
perfect diets at least you know you have
your bases covered in terms of the
micronutrients that you need it's very
easy to sign up you just go to
yourheits.com and then you sign up to
the thing and it's a mail order they get
to you every month or in three month
packets and if you use the coupon code
Ali 15 that's ali15 at checkout then
you'll get 15 off your first three
months of subscription I've been
subscribed to this for the last 12
months I also happen to be an investor
in the company because I believe in the
product and I love how they're fully
evidence-based and absolutely everything
they do and if you're interested in the
evidence base behind all like 20
different ingredients that they've got
here you can check them out on the
website and that'll be linked in the
video description and in the show notes
so thank you so much to Heights for
sponsoring this episode so let's say
someone's listening to this and they're
thinking all right cool I know I like
I've read Alex's birthday
me I've got I've got a seller thing I
don't I don't know what to sell I don't
know if I have any skills I don't I
don't I don't know what I could possibly
offer to the world yeah how do we how do
we break that down
yeah this is actually a topic that I um
I cover more in the leads book that's
coming out soon uh soon relative terms
six months-ish
everybody knows something all right and
so the idea is what do you have like
everyone has unique depth of knowledge
in certain areas because you've been
alive and your eyes and ears have taken
inputs period right and so I like to
think of of people starting like so if
you look at are you familiar with y
combinator
well I said yeah but so yeah yeah so why
combinator is one of the most successful
you know uh I don't know if they're
technically VC there's you know seed
Capital startup
um investors in Silicon Valley and they
have a very standard gel structure and
they have criteria for what they look
for in companies and one of the most
important criteria that they look for is
past experience and so they're okay with
somebody who's super young Etc but they
wanna they want you to have experience
in the industry because there's just so
much ignorance debt that you have to pay
down if you literally know nothing about
an industry like there's just so much
like if your dad was a mechanic you know
so much about cars just by osmosis of
being around a mechanic for 18 years and
so I like to think
past jobs you've held you will know
stuff about that industry
the jobs of your parents are things that
you will know about that industry and
then you've got personal interests and
so I think that if I put those into
three buckets it's like parent stuff
past jobs of self and current interests
and so it's like of those three things
which of those three buckets do you
think you could help someone do a thing
better
and so the idea is
you want to sell the most valuable thing
right and so the most valuable thing is
what is the problem that I can help
somebody else solve that I could charge
the most money for or in reverse that
could make them the most money and then
I will be able to charge a percentage of
the money that I'm able to make somebody
else in this thing now that's in a B2B
setting in a b2c setting it would be how
valuable do people perceive uh the
problem that they have as right whether
it's like I can teach music tons of
people want to be able to learn how to
and if you're better you know because
you've had a side interest in that
awesome maybe you have a side interest
because you're really good at editing
the songs well there's tons of musicians
who would love who hate that part and
would love to have it so it's like we
all know how to do stuff and all we have
to do is package the thing that we're
doing and I think the big problem is
that people expect that they're going to
have a perfect business but if you look
at the track record of all of I can't
think of an entrepreneur beside Chef
Bezos who's a freak of nature whose
first business becomes the most valuable
business in the world is most people
have a graveyard of failures behind them
and so the idea is you start not with
the intent of saying this is going to be
the one thing for the rest of my life
which is the fallacy that employees have
that whatever they pick as me they think
they're gonna do for the rest of their
lives when in relatives I just have to
do a thing that I'm good enough at that
I can learn the game and the thing is
once you start taking steps The Next
Step becomes illuminated you trying to
think a hundred steps into the future
when you have no context is is
irrelevant because chaos is going to
break your plan anyways and so do what
you know exchange I like service
businesses to start because they are the
in my opinion the lowest risk to start
because you're just it's just your time
right so service businesses meaning do
stuff for money
clean houses like whatever like all of
those are just service businesses right
and they're fine and a lot of people
think they need to have some novel idea
to start a business when I mean the best
in my opinion if you're if you're
getting into it the best way to start a
business is just look at what everyone
else is doing and just try and do it
better like that I mean and there's
obvious holes like if you've if you've
gone to if you've gotten your dry
cleaning it's like can I do this in half
the time as this guy if I do the lawn
care what are the things people hate
about lawn care they leave the the
trimmings around the edges they're all
shitty the person doesn't speak English
that well like well cool then I've got
advantages right so it's like what are
things that I already know how to do or
I have past experience in what things
because I have past experience I know
that other people struggle with that
sucks about this thing and then I will
solve that specific problem and it could
also be a problem that other people
solve too you just try and do a little
bit better like it's it's just not
rocket science you know what I mean and
then you exchange you start selling your
time for money so yes you're still
trading time for dollars you don't need
to read Rich Dad Poor Dad just yet right
you're still trading time for a dollar
right but the point is that you're
you're you're trading that time for
money in order to learn not to earn you
need to earn in order to pay your pay
your rent eat Etc but the the major
thing you're doing is you're paying down
ignorance debt so the vast majority of
your income is coming in the terms of in
the form of Education rather than
earning yeah there's a few a few things
that I think are really interesting uh
the first is that um I think if if we
think of sort of how an employee thinks
of us as how an entrepreneur thinks
we're a business owner an employee sort
of mindset is often sort of the activity
that I'm doing where the entrepreneur is
more like the problem the specific
problem that I'm solving
um and I found that when people in in
our team have started doing freelance
work and now they have more of an idea
of what a creative business looks like
and they can solve a specific problem
they're just like oh my God it's so easy
to make money whereas before they were
thinking of this service as like oh I am
I I offer writing as a service or
something like that but as soon as you
connect it to a problem that preferably
a business has because businesses can
pay for it suddenly the eyes light up
and you realize hang on what does money
even mean if I could if it's seemingly
so easy to make it
um yeah I I like what you're saying
about service based businesses because
it's it's not that sexy like when you
hear people on podcasts you don't tend
to hear of someone who built a service
based business and it went pretty big
you tend to hear the stories of like the
tech entrepreneurs that build it in the
built an Innovative product and stuff
um they don't see the 100 failed
startups like the failure rate on Tech
startups it might like is just as high
as everything else except it usually
takes capital and it doesn't take
Capital to start service business so
with you like my understanding is that
you quit your corporate job
um and started that started the gym
business and I wonder if we can kind of
explore explore the story there a little
bit more I can actually even rewind that
there was a half step in between there
so this is also covered in the leads
book but I'll give a I'll give a sneak
peek so what I did
um is I actually because I'd been
interested in Fitness right that was my
interest so like I had past experience I
I was obsessed with Fitness I've been at
that point I was 23. I've been training
for eight years I had several State
records so like I was a pretty you know
I was pretty into it right and it was to
the point where people were asking me
for stuff all you know workout programs
and things like just because they knew
my interest right and so as a as a quick
you know Pro tip for everybody if you've
got stuff that people ask you to do for
them because you're good at it maybe
you're good at Tech it's like can you
help me set up my like Wi-Fi and stuff
you know blah blah blah it's like that
means you're solving problems you can
chart like what people ask you to do as
a favor is an indication of the things
you can charge for later right so
I had all these people who are asking me
uh not all these I mean I had a full
people who had asked me for programs and
stuff and so what I did was during my
last year of Consulting I started
something called the free training
project and so the free training project
was I would charge 500 to a thousand
dollars but I would I wouldn't charge it
they had to donate that to the charity
their choice in exchange to work with me
right and so that way I wanted people to
Value it but they weren't paying me
directly so they'd get it right off they
felt good I had a ton of Goodwill also
in the marketplace too because I was
like I'm doing all this stuff for
charity I got I got all these people
reaching out to me like this is so cool
blah blah blah right
and so after a year of doing that I had
probably I don't know 12 really good
test of like great before and after
pictures that I had collected from my
clients and I told them that was part of
the deal I was like I'll like you have
to donate it I would like to do this for
real later but
um you have to let me use your
testimonial and they were like that's
fine so once I had that
um I had those first you know 10 12
customers who had who had great before
and after pictures
um I transitioned many of those
customers said hey I'm doing I'm going
to do this full time now are you
comfortable paying the same amount
you're paying to charity except just
making a charity of Alex because Alex
can't eat either and so and that was
actually how I transitioned from
not-for-profit or donating everything
and I'd even set up there today I just
told them to to literally donate it and
send me the screenshot I didn't even do
anything like that
um and so I didn't have a website
all I had was an LLC and a PayPal
account so like for everybody's like I
don't know how to start a business I was
like you literally just need a bank
account and a way to process money that
is it like two things and you can Google
how to figure out if you can't figure it
out from Google entrepreneurship might
not be for you all right but you look
like think about there's 30 million
business in the United States 30 million
other people have figured this out
which means you can too so bank account
payment processing make the first 10
free or some sort of charitable thing so
that people like don't feel weird or you
don't feel weird about selling Etc after
you have it after you're providing the
service to people you can transition
people from free service to paid service
and if they don't want to start paying
you then that gives you insight as to
either you suck right or they suck which
is also possible too but either way
a certain percentage of those people
will continue to stay and pay and now
you have income now you can also ask
those people for referrals which is
exactly what I did
um so I think half that business came in
just for I got you know the initial ones
came in from friends and family and me
posting and so I was I'll I'll close the
loop on what I said earlier a year later
after I had that testimonials I made a
public post being like hey I've got this
thing now I made a website which is that
was my big enough I made a website I
still have the post I found it it's
2013. I was like I made a I made a
website and uh I I am now open for
business and so if you would like you
know training stuff let me know
um this is what I'm doing now you know I
had some testimonials and go check out
the site whatever and so from there I
was able to get I think about 20 guys uh
who were willing to let me do just like
almost bodybuilding type stuff because I
was kind of like what I was powerless
back then and so
um I think I want to say I got 20 guys
at 200 bucks a month and so I was making
four thousand dollars a month uh from
those people and it took me four hours
every Saturday to do the Fulfillment
just a quick little break before we get
right back to the episode and that's
today you know that this episode is very
kindly brought to you by short form
short form is the world's best service
for reading summaries of books but it's
more than just book summaries what short
form does is it basically creates a sort
of study guide for tons and tons of
different non-fiction books from all
sorts of genres from self-help and
personal development to money and
history and philosophy it's just got
loads of really interesting books and
they summarize them firstly with a cool
one-page summary but then they also have
chapter by chapter outlines of each book
and in between the chapter summaries
they also have kind of interactive
exercise sections where you can take the
insights from the book and actually
apply them to your life and the other
cool thing about short form is that if
for example an author says something
that is a little bit dodgy or that has
been debunked or kind of disagreed with
with another author then the short form
team will write a note saying that hey
you know this person said this thing
about this topic but actually that has
been debunked by this other person and
they'll bring in another source and so
it's not just a way of getting summaries
of books it's also a way of expanding
your understanding of the genre as a
whole for example One summary I enjoyed
recently on short form is the summary of
The Elephant in the brain now this is a
book that I read like three years ago
and made a book summary of it for my
YouTube channel but it's been a while
since I read the book and so I found
myself wanting to revisit the key ideas
I often just open up short form when I'm
on the toilet and just look at the app
and see hey what's a book summary that I
want to read and I find it super helpful
to kind of re-jog my mind and to
re-think about kind of my own
motivations for doing things which is
kind of what the elephant in the brain
is about but I found it super helpful to
look at the short form summary to
revisit some of the ideas in the book
and this kind of tends to be how I use
short form either I use it as a way of
deciding whether I want to read a book
if it's new to me or I use it as a way
of revisiting ideas from books I've
already read so if any of that stands up
your street and you too would like to
try out the world's best service for
summarizing books then head over to
shortform.com forward slash deep dive
and firstly that will give you a
completely free five-day trial where you
can try it out and see if you like it
and it will also give you 20 off the
annual premium subscription which is the
thing that I personally subscribe to so
thank you so much short form for
sponsoring this episode so I feel like
we've got a good uh well a basic kind of
grounding in the importance of
dissocating them in regulating important
aspects of I guess physiology and
psychology
can we talk about
sleep now so I mean I read why we sleep
and I've listened to a bunch of podcast
episodes about this but I'd just love to
get your take on a few of these like
frequently asked questions about sleep
so
um I guess the first one that comes to
mind is
six hours seven hours eight hours nine
hours what what's going on there
um I think the key thing for me is that
uh one shoe size doesn't fit all right
and uh one of the sort of slight
frustrations that submerged is that an
average value is taken as the optimum
value for all of us and of course it
isn't uh across adults for example
healthy sleep can range from six hours
maybe slightly less than that out to 10
or 11 hours
and so yes there is an average uh but
actually there's so much individual
variation it's it's it's really I think
wrong to impose a specific amount for
each of us and the point of the book to
some extent is to allow people to Define
what's optimal for them how do I do that
how do you do that so yeah so how do you
know if you're not getting enough sleep
well it's it's the kind of things our
grandparents probably would have told us
if asked that question which is that
um do you need a partner or an alarm
clock to wake you up in the morning does
it take you a long time to wake up do
you crave caffeinated and sugar-rich
drinks during the day to keep you awake
have your friends family colleagues
reported that you're showing a lack of
empathy increased frustration they may
have noticed that you do stupid and
unreflective things
um and and when given the opportunities
to sleep let's say at the weekend and
very notably on holiday do do you find
your sleep patterns change and and it's
really defining what each of us needs
and then trying to adopt behaviors that
defend that sleep pattern and and you
know we know for example that the
duration of sleep varies enormously
between individuals but not only that
their timing going back to the molecular
clock uh there are subtle changes which
can make you a morning person or an
evening person but also going going back
to light
that can contribute to what's called
your chronotype your morningness and
eveningness so morning light advances
the clock make you makes you get up
earlier evening light delays the clock
makes you get up later and go to bed
later evening light is in dusk light
so dusk delays morning advances the
clock so you're constantly being nudged
backwards and forwards and of course one
of the problems of our society is that
we don't get asymmetrical exposure to
light which um can be a problem as in
you're not getting an equal amount of
advancing and delaying dawn dusk
exposure so we looked at a bunch of uh
University students around the world
um Australia New Zealand Germany Holland
and and in the UK and we show that those
were the latest chronotype those that
like to get up late and go to bed late
we're not getting warning light which
would have advanced the clock made them
get up earlier they were missing that
they'll be sleeping through the morning
but they were getting evening light
which would delay the clock which causes
them to sleep even though yeah so our
sleep timing is dependent upon our
genetics
um uh and when we see light but also
there's another factor which is how old
we are so from about the age of 10
there's a tendency to want to go to bed
later and later and later peaks in
lateness in males about 21 21 and a half
in females about 19. so men tend to be
later for longer and then as we age we
sort of move to a more morning
chronotype the time we're in our late
50s early 60s we're getting up and going
to bed at about the time we got up and
went to bed when we were 10. and that
actually changed almost perfectly
correlates with the changing levels of
estrogen and testosterone so that sharp
rise during puberty and then the sort of
decline in into old age so the point I'm
making is that not only is there lots of
differences between individuals in terms
of their their preference for how long
they want to sleep and when they want to
sleep but it changes as we age therefore
it's completely Daft to try and Define
the optimum sleep you know at stage the
optimum sleep duration you must get
eight hours
um and and I I think it was kicking back
against that
which was one of the reasons for for
writing the book I mean people have
actually come up to me after a public
talk and this is before lockdown and one
person said to me I don't get eight
hours of sleep am I going to die and I
said well I can assure you you're going
to die but but it may have nothing to do
with your secret and so people have
become
um frightened about their sleep rather
than embracing the Sleep uh that they
get they become anxious about it there
there was and it's reinforced by Sleep
apps it's worth bearing in mind that at
the moment No Sleep apps are are
um endorsed by any of the sleep
federations or FDA approved and of
course you know when you look at the
validation of many of these these apps
um you'll go into the paper and you'll
see it work perfectly for eight
undergraduates you know or uh in
California and that's about it but of
course the point I've just made is that
sleep changes as we um age and between
individuals and so one algorithm is also
not appropriate for telling us what good
sleep is people have come to me and said
oh do you believe in slow wave sleep and
I've sort of said yes kind of why and
they said well I didn't think I'm
getting any because my app is telling me
I don't get any slow way of sleep and of
course these apps are
found the
um uh they're just they can't detect
that they don't have the sensitivity to
do that and so people can get very badly
misled so so so there's a sort of the
mantras that are a bit frustrating you
must do this you must do that but it's
reinforced by sleep app saying we had a
good night's sleep or a bad night's
sleep and again we should be listening
to our own biology using very
straightforward
um uh sort of criteria that we've just
touched upon nice okay I have another
um potential myth that maybe you can
debunk which I wish I've heard a lot
which is that you might think you can
get by with six hours of sleep but when
you're 65 you're more likely to get
dementia and Alzheimer's and stuff so
make sure you get your eight hours yeah
it's a good point I mean I would not
want to marginalize the importance of
sleep absolutely but I do think that we
need to take responsibility for it now
if you are in your middle years and you
are you know doing crazy sorts of things
in terms of business and all the rest of
it and and are chronically sleep
deprived then there is evidence that
chronic sleep deprivation in the middle
years will predispose your risk or
increase your risk to Alzheimer's and
Dementia so I think that's a serious
issue but but again it's horses for
courses
um and I think most people know if
they're they're not getting the sleep
that they need yeah
um how important is it to wake up at the
same time every day I think it is
important because it reinforces all of
the sort of signals that regulate the
Circadian system so eating at the same
time uh getting light exposure at the
same time that all acts to stabilize
however having said that you know
there's going to be an occasion where
you have a party you're going to get up
late you know and sleep is is is very
Dynamic it's it's and I really can't
emphasize one size does not fit at all
and and and because it's such a dynamic
and variable behavior um we can you know
it's it can be tweaked and it's flexible
um yeah the other the other really
interesting myth that so many again
again people sort of perpetuate the myth
it's not only eight hours but it's eight
hours of uninterrupted sleep
and and of course what we know from uh
Roger Eckert's work uh from his
historical studies looking at sleep
patterns in the pre-industrial era is
that human sleep almost certainly wasn't
a single eight-hour block uh so so you
hear in the literature I had a wonderful
first sleep
um and uh you know I didn't have such a
great second sleep and there's Roger
talks about a wonderful
um French uh Doctor Who says uh young
couples should make love after their
first sleep uh when they are less tired
and will be better at it I mean you know
so you've got this literature which sits
out there and that then encouraged
people like Tom Weir to say okay well
let's find out what happens to modern
humans if we bring them into the lab
give them 12 hours of light 12 hours of
darkness and lo and behold you get
what's called biphasic uh a couple of
episodes of sleep separated by wake or
indeed polyphasic which is multiple
sleeps with interruptions throughout the
night if you look at all mammals again
that wonderful comparative perspective
all mammals show they don't show a
Consolidated bunch of snake it's it's
polyphasic or biphasic and indeed
societies today without electric light
show multiple wakings and seepings so
that bit of information is not out there
and so when people wake up in the middle
of the night think oh my God that's it
I'm never going to get back to sleep I'm
as I start drinking coffee and do my
emails which is nonsense if they stay
calm you don't necessarily have to stay
in bed you can keep the lights low do
something relaxing you will feel tired
again and then go back to sleep I read
somewhere that you had you were into
like mindfulness and meditation and like
what was your journey with those things
so my mom used to do it and she used to
try to get me to meditate when I had
Tourette's and that didn't work so
um many years later
uh it's this is actually during lockdown
so I had this crazy experience where
I didn't see people very much and and
then when I did for some reason I was
getting so socially anxious
and it could be something like sitting
in the car with a really good friend
like my best friend I could be in the
car with him
and I should basically have a panic
attack
and it really came out of nowhere and
I'm not sure if it's related to just
stress at the time or
I still don't know why it happened but I
I sought out therapy and uh yeah we
worked through it but one of the things
the guy recommended was to meditate and
so I downloaded the Calm app and uh I I
I learned about
experiencing feelings in my body and
thoughts and kind of noticing them for
what they are and not taking them as
seriously as I used to but yeah that
said it was still it doesn't just fix it
it's not one of those things I think
some people think like if I meditate 10
times this week everything's gonna be
good you still have there's still other
factors at play but over time it's
definitely kind of helped
um alongside
just doing things again and doing things
that I'm uncomfortable with
uncomfortable with so yeah like for
example with podcasts yeah
um
you know I'm not asked on that many
podcasts but I've been asked on probably
10 podcasts this year
and I've said no to every single one
and
because I was like What if I have a
panic attack while I'm doing a podcast
which is you'd probably look at me now
and you're like you probably don't seem
like that
um
but but yeah so I was avoiding it and
then I was like I got the DM from you
and I'm already getting a lot better
like the last kind of year and a half
I've just been trying to do things that
make me scared and I was like okay this
is a great opportunity he seems like a
really nice guy this is not going to be
intimidating and now I'm gonna do it and
even before this I'm obviously I was
pretty nervous
um but
but now I've done it I'm gonna probably
do more and so that's also my advice is
one is meditating
but two if something really scares you
obviously don't jump right into the deep
end but try and do it because it's way
worse in your head
uh especially things like sitting in the
car with my friend I mean there's
nothing dangerous about that but
something about that was was giving me
anxiety and you didn't have anxiety
before this
um not so much no no but but I think it
is related Tourette's I mean Tourette's
add bit of OCD all of these things are
kind of related uh so yeah you know uh
it's something it's something my you
know my mom struggled with my sister
struggles with so
yeah but I think you know again it's one
of those things which at the time it's
it sucks and and so on but if you can
use it to teach yourself lessons and
also appreciate when you're not feeling
anxious and you're just like wow I feel
normal
um and then you just enjoy simple things
then then it's actually a bit of a power
to what what does your meditation
practice look like
so it's it's super competitive the
opposite of what meditation should be I
uh no I I basically sit down
um and and listen to to calm what's her
name on calm is this one Teresa is the
name Teresa or something everyone people
in the comments will know who I'm
talking about uh and she basically does
a guided meditation and I do that
um but sometimes even even before I'm
doing something that's difficult I'll
just take some time to breathe I'll no
matter what happens I'll feel nervous
like I can't stop that and but I'll
notice what that is and I'll be like
okay
what's the worst that can happen
you can end up in hospital
what's the worst that can happen you
could die okay that sucks I'm just
surprising here
okay that's that's what you usually goes
to my friend so then what do you do but
let's just go and do it no you gotta you
just gotta and then
I just feel like you just you
you breathe
you can even get things like this which
you might think why do I have this and
when I first met you we shook hands and
I had it in my hand probably I remember
yeah but this is like it's just like
something I can play with it distracts
me things like that you just come up
with your own like come up with your own
stories of things that work for you
maybe going for a run for example in the
morning could also help uh kind of
really stress things like that
um makes life quite fun
trying to like yeah it's coming up with
ways to get through things and then the
best thing is once you finally do
something you're really nervous about or
you struggled with in the past and you
actually do it there's no better feeling
like after this podcast I'm just gonna
go home being like yeah yeah I did it
battled through exactly
yeah so this is something I've been I've
been looking into a fair bit I mean
firstly thank you for being so open this
is great like um I'm sure there are
people listening to this who have
whoever well that's really originating
with all of the things you're saying and
like oh my God thank God someone's
talking about this well I saw I think
saw Lewis Capaldi recently talked about
this that's that makes me feel good look
it's not just me so yeah because you're
seeing him struggle makes me feel great
yeah especially with a lot of a lot of
the mental health stuff as well like
it's it's so easy to think that this is
just the way I am this is normal and
that no one else has has those struggles
yeah hearing kind of people like you
being open about it on podcasts it's
just like super nice and yeah thank you
I've been
doing a bunch of research for the book
that I'm writing around
um like uh energy and and like uh
sympathetic versus parasympathetic
nervous system
um I'll pretend I know what those mean
sympathetic nervous system in a way when
you're in sort of stress mode when
you're outside yeah and you literally
you know this stuff well can you give me
a session
yeah I'll give it a go
um but there's is sort of even people
who say that they don't who wouldn't
identify with struggling with anxiety
there's some stat that like 75 of the
workforce in at least in the US
feels that sort of sympathetic
activation in that sort of stress
anxious mode while they're at work
and you know there's a lot of stuff
around how evolutionarily it made sense
that you know there was a bit of a
threat in the grass and now you want to
be in fight-or-flight mode because you
might have to run away from a tiger but
you know having a conversation with your
boss at work or being in the car with
your friend like you wear the the brain
tricks us into being in reactive flight
fight or flight mode
and weirdly there's like so much science
around just like deep breathing like you
know short took it sympathetic mode
activates parasympathetics which is like
rest and recharge mode
and retraining again I'm not going to
know the words that you know like
retraining those those things in your
brain that kind of
every time at that point when I didn't
want to get in the car I was like every
time I go to a car it just happened
and
you just gotta slowly learn how to deal
with it and eventually you can retrain
your mind not to have that feeling and
so that's why you know people who who
get to where they get to it it's from
practice they don't not everyone starts
off super confident and uh and and uh
able to do everything it takes time and
that's why I love hearing people like
Lewis Capaldi or whoever it is saying
like how difficult it was how have your
attitudes towards money changed from
kind of age 14 thinking of Mercedes-Benz
cost 500 quid and making you know a few
quit an hour to you know having a
life-changing exit like what was that
that Journey
so I think at the beginning I think this
also the case with quite a lot of people
I think at the beginning I had quite a
scarcity mindset towards money
um I very much was like oh I've got this
I have to make sure that you know it
doesn't go
and I think over time because I've
proved to myself that I've become the
type of person who can create value and
make money I now approach it with a lot
more
abundance a lot more like oh yeah cool
that's fine okay this happens this
happens and I'm very aware that it's
very I guess like fortunate uh position
to be in but like
think that was a big change was just
going from scarcity to abundance and
you know every time you'd hear people
say like you know money doesn't make you
happy Etc it's like like yes that's true
but I'm also significantly happier right
and like
um
um I'm also significantly happier than I
was
like when I didn't have it so
um those will probably be the two main
ones but I think definitely going from
scarcity to abundance and actually think
a mental trick I should have done when I
was younger was I think I should have
tried to like program my mind to think
more in abundance rather than waiting
for the money to come to then think in
abundance
that was a mistake if I had treated
money as more like uh oh you know like
you know it Ebbs and it flows it goes
from here it goes from here I just need
to become the type of person who can do
it blah blah like I would not have held
on to things for too long and I also
would not have made certain decisions
which were based out of like I don't
want to lose
um rather than now I'm just like oh cool
whatever so let's say someone's
listening to this and they currently
have a scarcity mindset towards money
and they're thinking I'll tell him easy
for you to say you've got I know
um that was me yeah uh what would be the
instructions that the the code for the
firmware update to get that mental model
of money the one that's more abundant
rather than scarce assuming you don't
have several zeros after your bank
account balance
money comes as a result of the person
that you are and the person that you are
is by and large a consequence of like
the skills and the habits that you have
so rather than optimizing for the money
like focus on like skill acquisition
right for example with me I really
in our first two years and really in our
first yeah three four years
all the brands that came to us were due
to inbound like they'd come to us rather
than us going directly to them and it's
because we became very good at like
building marketing funnels and all that
stuff that brought in Brands and I
learned those funnels from like again
Russell Brunson and all these guys so
I'd build all these funnels that'll
become the like foundation of the
business and that will bring people in
so I thought more about like the skills
I was cultivating and as a consequence
of those skills I was then able to
create something of value and then those
things are valued and made me money so
to that you know young person thinking
that I'd say yes a
I know it's incredibly
um challenging to think like that when
you don't have money but it's very
important to focus on like the skills
and actually cultivating skills which
can then lead to money which is things
like you know marketing and sales and uh
copywriting things like that like you
want to focus on just like being off
used to the economy because if you're of
like General use in some way people will
pay you for that and like that's the way
that you create value it's almost like
leveling up in a video game yeah if you
want if you want to get the gear to take
down that end game Boss you need to
level up yeah you need to do all this
stuff level up yeah train up to these
different trade skills that's why I was
talking about cheat codes yeah actually
with the book
um with a book one of the titles one of
the suggested titles was basically
around cheat codes it was like it was
something like
it's basically like how to discover the
cheat codes to winning in business and
life or something Dan actually told me
not to go with that title because he
said that you don't want to be linked
with the word cheating so I was like
okay cool but but um but I do see it as
a game
um I've just you know figuring out the
inputs okay that worked that didn't work
done yeah yeah this is something I was
talking about with um Alexi as well in
in the podcast
um this idea that
like I know so many people who who like
come to me and they're like hey Ali you
know you know about this investing stuff
you know I'm I'm currently making I
don't know 50k in my job and I'm saving
10 and I want to put it in the you know
index funds or like individual stocks
and I'm like
I mean the right answer is index funds
but actually the that's the wrong answer
because what you're gonna earn three
four six percent and when you're 55 then
then you'll be good like instead if you
can find a way to invest those things in
your own education yeah so that you
become the sort of person who then can
command a premium yeah and can just make
money yeah individual that's way more
Roi positive yeah and the way homozy
describes it is that it's investing in
the s p versus the S and me oh that's
good there you go yeah I mean you know
like people talk about companion
interest but you almost want to you know
compound yourself yeah like that's way
better if you if you
the Returns on compounding yourself are
way more than any stock right yeah than
you could ever
more than any crypto yeah and I guess
almost the there's like a tier list of
this almost where it's like most like
the the top returns are encompanying
yourself the second top returns are are
in investing in your own business yeah
and then worst case scenario S P 500
okay once you once you have literally no
other options and the money's just
sitting there burning a hole in your
account yeah okay fine yeah let's try
and go for seven percent to be inflation
but like there are so many options
beyond that point yeah but I think
people default to oh I should invest
because especially I think in
traditional Fields like I know so many
doctors who feel like they don't have
any skills outside of medicine how do
you make money investing is the only
option yeah um rather than I actually
could start a business yeah I could
learn how to do that yeah you want to
almost like see yourself
one of the things that I say to friends
is that you want to see yourself as like
a SIMS character oh okay tell me more
that you're almost just like there and
you're playing Sims and like you're the
character and then it's like okay go
left all right cool it's like go to gym
I go to the gym I do this all right do
not eat now okay I shall not eat now
right like I type on laptop right cool
so
when you have a SIMS character and you
just like tell it to do stuff it just it
just like goes and does stuff and I've
often tried to see my life as a bit of a
SIMS character like I am now in good
shape and beforehand I was not in good
shape and I was like okay what are the
two things that I need to do to be in
good shape well eat less move more done
right so I eat less so sometimes I'll be
hungry and I'm like well I'm not gonna
eat now okay I don't eat right
um I'm not gonna you know move more gym
cool I now go to the gym so I think I
treat myself almost like a SIMS
character because I'm just like whoa
foreign if a SIMS character can do it
then why can't you you know
um that's kind of the mentality that I
have towards us life in general of it
there are certain components to deep and
Lasting attraction
you have chemistry
um
perceived value
perceived challenge
and connection
the reason I like this model is because
when you look at this you can usually
see you can sort of self-diagnose
where something may be going wrong
chemistry is interesting because there's
certain there's a certain intangible
there and an unknown there and not we
certainly can't control all of it but we
can control some of it you know with the
way the way that we look how well we
take care of ourselves the way we move
importantly is a big factor in chemistry
um which is why you can sometimes see
someone in photos and think they're
really attractive and then you meet them
in real life and you kind of go Oh weird
I don't feel the same way it's also why
you can get back from a date and and say
oh my God I just had this amazing date
with this incredibly hot person and if
you show pictures of that person to your
friends they're like
okay yeah
I guess you know because you you were
there yeah you were there you saw how
they move how they smile how they
gesture how they their micro Expressions
so there's certainly things we can do to
affect chemistry uh and obviously you
can create tension too which is a big
factor in chemistry in chemistry then
there's perceived value and perceived
value is all these things that that we
are and do that bring value to the table
it might be our personality uh it might
be the things that we're good at in life
it might be our life the life that we've
built
um can sometimes be our friends and
family you know sometimes you meet
someone's friends and family and you go
whoa this is what a life this is to come
into they have an amazing group of
people around them so much love so much
so there's a lot of ways for perceived
value to to manifest itself then there's
perceived challenge
and the interesting thing about
perceived value is it goes down
regardless of how many things are in
that category
if there's no perceived Challenge
and perceived challenge is not uh
the kind of
I don't know a typical way of thinking
about it I guess would be like hard to
get
it's not that's a cheap way to create
challenge because the problem with hard
to get is you can't keep it up forever
the moment you oh God yeah
if someone's if your attraction was
built around the getting then you can't
sustain it
but if
the the real beautiful sustainable way
to create challenge is for there to be
uh for your value to have a price
okay what do you mean
that your value doesn't come for free
your value is something that has to be
earned
by the someone showing up in the way
you're prepared to show up by someone
being prepared to make the kind of
sacrifices you're prepared to make for
someone
um by someone giving to you on a level
that you're willing to give respecting
you on a level that that you respect
them
um
and also not giving someone too much
credit too quickly
that's a a big problem when we come from
a needy place when we come from a place
of insecurity we start giving people
credit they don't deserve yet
I just met them I just had the most
amazing date with the most amazing
person oh my God they're incredible
based on what
based on how on what basis what
information could you have possibly got
on one date
that enables you to say this
you
you have been seduced by a kind of charm
Charisma maybe the fact that you did
something really fun on the day the fact
that they made you laugh a lot the fact
that they told stories about their past
that made them relatable or sympathetic
or seem really authentic all of that is
great I'm not I'm not saying be
inherently suspicious I'm saying
you don't know yeah
you don't know so on what basis are you
giving them all of this value already
based on projection
and based on insecurity this immediate
putting them on a pedestal and putting
yourself down here and when someone
smells that
they don't see an equal anymore
and that's that's what I mean when I say
challenge I don't mean artificially
constructing
games or Hoops for people to jump
through
I mean that the the criteria you have
for someone has to be real yeah it has
to be real like
it's you and I met today for the first
time
really enjoying our conversation hope
you are too absolutely you know but we
don't know each other yet as friends you
don't know if I'd be reliable if you
needed something you don't know if I
would show up to support you if
something went wrong in your life you
don't know you don't know any of that
so
you know it would be dangerous to go
away and make a an assessment on how
great of a friend I would be yep based
on this exchange it what what you would
hope in an organic situation is that you
and I go
this was really really fun we got on
really well this was a great
conversation I would like to get to know
this guy better that would be like it'd
be really cool if we could hang out
outside of the podcast
but it's not I have to be friends with
with Ali you know like we I have to
because he's a he's an amazing guy you
know like yeah that's that now that's
projection that's dangerous because I'm
basing that on the fact that you're
clearly outwardly a very impressive
human and what you've achieved what
you've done is very impressive and you
seem to have had a really amazing kind
of impact on a lot of people and those
are all amazing things those are amazing
things in their own right
it's not about devaluing those
but
I have no idea what your value would be
as a friend
until we try being friends
and the mistake people make in dating
commonly
is they look at someone's
stats
how Charming were they how charismatic
were they how successful are they
um you know where are they in their life
what kind of person do they seem to be
but none of that exists in relation to
to you
that's all just you admiring
what this person has or is
but none of it says this person is going
to be a great boyfriend or a great
girlfriend none of it says they're going
to be loyal none of it says they're
going to be reliable none of it says
they're going to be a great teammate all
it says is this person seems on these
metrics
to be attractive and in any relationship
you have to go through for for in terms
of importance you have to go through
four stages
one is admiration that's just where I
can see someone and admire them from
either up close or far wow this person's
pretty impressive and attractive not
very important in the stages not
important yeah necessary but not
important yep
then there's uh a connection
or chemistry you both you need you know
that's the next stage of do we feel
connected to each other and is there a
kind of chemistry all right now it's
slightly more important because now it
becomes Mutual yeah now it's not just me
admiring you it's oh there's something
between us yeah
not important
because necessary yeah but not important
how many people have ruined their lives
over the fact that they had chemistry
with someone even when that person was a
terrible partner a terrible person to
base their their decisions on
the next stage is uh
commitment
okay I admire you we have mutual
chemistry and connection and we're both
actually saying yes to each other I deal
with people every day where they have
this stage
but that person isn't saying yes
they're saying yeah I'd like to see you
this Friday
at 11 o'clock
but they're not saying yes to an actual
relationship
so you need commitment to go to the next
stage of importance but many people are
treating something like it has total
importance even though they're only at
the second stage so you need a yes you
need commitment
now you would say if you've got that
that's the most important thing you can
have you've got someone you admire
you've got someone you have a connection
with in chemistry and you've got someone
who is committed
it would seem like that was everything
but that kind of idea is it Virgil would
love conquers all love does not conquer
all
two people saying yes to each other
doesn't
make for a long-term relationship you
also have to have the fourth stage of
importance which is compatibility yeah
are you actually compatible because if
you're not
you can say yes I want to be with you
yes I'm committed
but that lack of compatibility will show
up in ways that will make both of you
miserable well what do you mean by
compatibility it could be anything it
could be my idea of a good time is
staying home watching movies and yours
is constantly traveling around the world
it could be your idea of a good time is
going out and drinking and doing drugs
and I don't want to live that life and
we've both said yes to each other
but
the you know our idea of what is a good
life is completely different or our idea
of loyalty is completely different your
idea of loyalty is that I don't have sex
with anyone my idea of loyalty is that
you don't emotionally cheat on me
in the texts you send yep you know that
we've both said yes to each other we
have admiration connection commitment
and yet I am miserable because of what
your definition of loyalty is
so compatibility is do we both want to
live the same kind of life and and do
our values line up and do we both have
the same idea two people can say I value
kindness but we can have very different
standards
for what kindness actually means
so
without that stage so many things go
wrong my
what what I mean to say with all of this
is that
we lose our value in dating
when we stop paying attention
to the appropriate level of importance
at different stages
if you
take stage two
I found someone I have a connection with
as the be-all end-all and the thing that
you
martyr yourself in service of
you lose all your value
you you are now the person who spends a
lifetime uh accepting really poor
treatment from someone because every
time you see them it's amazing you don't
understand when we're together it's so
good it's so incredible they're so there
for me that the sex is amazing the
chemistry is amazing we have such
amazing conversations
what's the problem I haven't heard from
them in two weeks
but Matt you don't understand the
connection is incredible you don't know
like this this is really important to me
why
why because you you have miscalculated
the value of stage two and when you do
that you lose your value because someone
realizes your value what you're willing
to give has no price
it's free it does not need to be earned
so your perceived challenge
drops and when you're perceived when
there's no challenge to you when someone
realizes your value has no price
then you lose respect and you and you
end up losing real value as a result
which is crazy but I know it all sounds
kind of heady but it
you know it really this stuff is real
whether you whether when someone
there'll be people listening to this uh
guarantee there'll be someone in the
comments
who says oh does it all need to be so
difficult can't you just be yourself and
the answer is no
because you may not be doing the things
that make you confident or that show
your real value you shouldn't be uh
someone you're not
but people Define being themselves as
holding on to all of their the things
that make them make bad decisions or
that make them uh their trauma or the
things that they haven't healed or the
things that make them chase after
someone who will ruin their life that's
not being yourself that's that's not
healing that's not doing the things that
are necessary for you to attract a much
more quality version of connection and
love in your life you have written and
talked a lot about the concept of row
yeah what is row so pronounced rule in
Swedish it's just another word I don't
think anyone really thinks about it more
than any other word but it's a word that
doesn't have
um direct translation to any other
language that I know of at least not
English basically what it means
through is just like calm Tranquility
peace
um so if you've had like a long day you
might say in Swedish
I
just want some peace and calm or
I want to find a place to have some rule
um
and I started because
a lot of
but somehow my philosophy in life is
goes back to rule essentially means that
even at the end of the day if I've had a
long day or stressful day I always want
to feel like I'm coming back to a place
where I feel like I can rest and relax
and feel it calm
on the inside and I try to create those
habits
in my everyday life I want my home to be
that place I want to have that feeling
with my close relationships where I can
feel like this person
gives me some rule as opposed to the
opposite of giving me stress or anxiety
or
um
yeah so I think that's just where it
started I was like this is a great word
and more people should know of this word
or concept and I started my newsletter
named it Monday Monday I think I haven't
been writing a lot there but um
basically just writing
stories of rule or tips on Rue and
things like that and a lot of people
enjoyed it and resonated with the
concept of just wanting more through in
their lives and that's how that was born
yeah
um how how does one go about finding
um good good pronunciation
[Music]
um
give me different things to different
people so like having it all in the
morning to me is just
not feeling stressed in the morning and
waking up early enough to where I can
have a coffee and sit on my couch and
cuddle my dog and not have to hurry
anywhere or feel like I'm
stressed out and that I'm well rested so
that's just a way if I need it or I love
taking long walks and not listening to
anything and just enjoying the walk with
no sounds and to me that's true so I
think
it means different things to different
people but I think the feeling is just
simply
it's a bit meditative where it's like
it's like the feeling where you're
taking a long walk in the forest or
something and you don't have any
distractions other than bird sounds or
you know the sound of bushes or whatever
something that is just very peaceful and
calming and
yeah I think it's going to be different
things for different people but you're
gonna know if you start paying attention
to your day like where do I feel like
I'm
at ease where do I feel like no one is
bothering me there's like a calm feeling
throughout my body and I'm just being
and
what is that to you can you identify
anything like that in your life yeah
yeah very much so I was just thinking as
you were saying about that like your
whole vibe is very like Rue how nice
very like kind of Zen kind of like calm
and tranquil and
it's just a sort of just like sitting
here talking to you is making me just
feel a bit more calm I'm just like yeah
this is falling asleep I had a nice
conversation I feel like I'm relaxed I
feel like I'm I'm energized and well it
was sort of like uh being energized
through being relaxed yeah rather than
being energized through being like
frantic almost yeah so it's not
necessarily to me it's not like feeling
sleepy or you know taking a nap it is
feeling energized but through something
very simple and calming so journaling
can be pretty
pretty much that as well depending on
what you're writing about that you're
ranting about a recent heartbreak maybe
it's not very robot
can you find anything specific in yeah
so I've been thinking about this sort of
concept A Lot recently
um because with the book that I'm
working on
um
the core thesis I guess is that
you know for me productivity has always
been about trying to trying to get
energy from my work so that I can give
energy to the things that I want to do
outside of work
and I find that the way I get energy
from my work is by approaching it in
this sort of
with lightness and ease and tranquility
and remembering to have fun with it and
remembering that
I don't need to be stressed out and I
think it's it's easy to
and even even had this when I when I
wasn't working for myself so when I was
working as a doctor it's it's very easy
to sort of approach it with a frantic
energy of like oh [ __ ] all this [ __ ]
needs to be done and stuff
yeah
um and I found that on days where I
would have that attitude towards it I
would just feel completely drained and
it wasn't fun
but on days where I had exactly the same
to-do list but I approached it with a
sense of
I've got a lot of things to do today
this is going to be fun yeah
um there's a there's a quote from Gray's
Anatomy where um Patrick Dempsey the
neurosurgeon he always starts his
operations with uh it's a beautiful day
to save lives let's have some fun nice
and I sometimes think about that as
being like that is actually a way of
approaching anything it's a beautiful
day to save lives let's have some fun
regardless of what's actually happening
in the thing and so I try and remind
myself to do that with with work staff
or whenever I feel frantic or harried in
any kind of way yeah just taking that
breath
I mean like no it's all good and I can
choose to approach this with I guess
root rather than yeah totally I think I
think attitude is like I know some
people get annoyed when you talk about
just have a positive attitude or a good
attitude but I really think that it does
so much to how you approach things and
how you see things like if I think to
myself okay I have to create this video
this week and I have to do this and that
and I kind of stress myself up
of all the things that I have to do and
accomplish and the time that I have
doing it in deadlines I'm just going to
be stressed out I'm not going to enjoy
the process as much and it's probably
not going to turn out as well either
because it's going to start feeling like
this thing that I just have to do rather
than this thing that I want to do
if I Instead try to be like okay I have
to write the script I'm gonna grab my
coffee I'm gonna sit on the couch I'm
gonna put my dog in my lap and we're
gonna go about this and
somehow we feel like if we have more of
a calm approach to things we're not as
productive you know it's not as
efficient you kind of
I can at least feel sometimes like okay
why am I not feeling
too stressed about this does that mean
that I'm slacking even if I'm getting as
much done and getting it done better
than I would have had otherwise
there's something
enemy and maybe you and other people
where you kind of feel like being
productive means that you need to feel
like you're running around and you're
doing this and that and you're switching
between tasks and you're like you want
to feel a little bit stressed that can
sometimes make you feel like you're
being more productive whereas if you're
drinking coffee and you're just kind of
having this calm Vibe you might feel
like you're not being as productive even
if you are so I'm just trying to lean
into the fact that I can actually
approach things
be more
chill with that Gray's Anatomy quote
attitude and I can still heal the same
results and enjoy the process a lot more
yeah
yeah have you come across uh Derek
sivers I don't think so he's like this
uh you know he used to be an
entrepreneur I sold his money a sold his
company for a lot of money and then
decided to live the chill life of kind
of doing what he wants and he's he's
written a couple of really good books
about like like intentional living and
stuff
um but there's a really good story that
he talks about of how you know he I
think he used to live in like Australia
or something and he used to sort of
cycle the length of some psychopath and
he would always try and like go as fast
as possible and he'd be like okay you
need to beat 42 minutes need to be 42
minutes and 42 minutes was his number
um and then one day he decided you know
what I'm just gonna take a chill like
I'm actually good I'm not gonna huff and
puff I'm gonna enjoy and I'm gonna enjoy
the cycle ride as I'm going along and
you know he was like I'm not going to
turn myself I'm just going to go around
the cycle you know I'm gonna um might
like waver some people along the way
listen to the birds I really enjoy
myself and he gets back home and he
looks at his clock and it's 44 minutes
and he's like [ __ ] well for the last
like six months have I just been huffing
and puffing for the sake of two minutes
like what the [ __ ] yeah and now he like
I think there's a a wider message in
that yeah
huffing and puffing actually does not
necessarily lead to the outcome that you
think it's going to get to alright so
that's it for this week's episode of
Deep dive thank you so much for watching
or listening all the links and resources
that we mentioned in the podcast are
going to be linked down in the video
description or in the show notes
depending on where you're watching or
listening to this if you're listening to
this on a podcast platform then do
please leave us a review on the iTunes
Store it really helps other people
discover the podcast or if you're
watching this in full HD or 4k on
YouTube then you can leave a comment
down below and ask any questions or any
insights or any thoughts about the
episode that would be awesome and if you
enjoyed this episode you might like to
check out this episode here as well
which links in with some of the stuff
that we talked about in the episode so
thanks for watching uh do hit the
Subscribe button if you aren't already
and I'll see you next time bye